good morning gamers it's another
beautiful day
in minecraft and today we have a lot of
a lot of epic stuff to do i'm actually
recording this intro
after the video because i forgot to make
one
so first off i've been cheating on you
guys i live streamed yesterday
because i need wither skulls our goal in
this series right now
our number one priority is to breed
our pig army and make it as strong as
possible
then what we're gonna do is we're gonna
make our pig army fight
one of the bosses of minecraft the
wither now to kill the wither you need
three uh skull thingies which drops in
the nether
i played yesterday on the live stream
and let's just cut to that footage just
to give you guys in summary what
happened i
enchanted my axe and was crazy lucky and
got a great enchantment
whoa damn
then i enchanted my sword and was even
more lucky
sharpness three sweeping edge three
fire aspects too i think that's pretty
good
that's already so good all right
then the wither skull which has a 5.5
percent chance of dropping
drops on the first spawns
that's pretty smart to put in a hallway
whoa
whoa i'm so lucky dude already
and if that wasn't enough i dropped
another one right after
oh my god
[Music]
dude looting three baby i'm a lucky boy
this live stream was lucky boy then pig
explosion thing happened
pig man get out of the way
[Music]
oh pigment
then i got a third one come on
bring it
yeah then i got a fourth one
oh my god then i built this
ugly spawner this spawner is gonna work
so good
when i wake up tomorrow damn
dude i'm gonna get so much items damn
just wait until tomorrow you guys
criticize my spawner
just wait until tomorrow like you're
gonna feel
awful this is gonna work yeah it's gonna
work
tomorrow when i wake up i'm gonna have
so much stuff
dude and that's where the live stream
ended
oh you hear that time to check the chat
whoa i got the scaffold
how could this possibly have failed
hi guys i guess you didn't oh no
okay all right
all right all right i guess they didn't
die
[Music]
wow look at that yeah
oh look i have new friends in both hello
new friends in boat
ah how does that make any sense stop
francine
stop printing boat oh he's shooting his
friend in his friend boat
oh no you're on fire now all right we're
going together now
i don't care what you think about me
we're going to be friends
just go in there
[Music]
hey kid like here bird you
come back here hey can't like here
once i'm through with you you're gonna
feel the pressure
the pain the pleasure of pain oh my
god stop i hate you
say your last sorry
i care
the parrot oh my god it's so cute
[Music]
here i'll give you my seed oh you like
that
or that you just like it he's sitting is
he sitting
[Music]
he's blue too yes yes
yes that's so awesome
[Music]
was like father to me
how could this happen
it hurts it really does
ah water sheep oh gracious water she
why does everyone i love die
oh my gosh no no
no oh okay he's fine he's fine how do
you make pants in minecraft
oh man it's so expensive
uh so as you can tell
it's getting very expensive to keep up
this beautiful diamond armor so what you
can do in minecraft
is that you can make a villager into a
librarian
but what's even better is if you cure a
villager and if you remember if you
watched series epically which of course
you have
this is intense yo they got villagers
apparently you can cure them we have one
of those we need to prepare for the
weather as best as we can
okay so to cure a villager we need one
golden apple my gosh
expensive and a potion of weakness
for that we need a fermented ill
fermented spider eye
brown mushroom and sugar
how do we make sugar you can make sugar
in minecraft from sugar canes okay
all right that makes sense hey remember
when i had a sugarcane farm and then i
said
i don't need that anymore oh okay thank
god i saved some
is my spawner working oh my gosh there's
so many of them there that's awesome
i feel like there has to be there has to
be mushrooms in the mine somewhere
oh my gosh there's diamond here
what how did i not see
this
[Music]
oh oh i guess i haven't really showed
like my mining area
it's not that interesting that's why
i tried to make a spawner here but
they're poison spiders which is just
obnoxious to even try and do anything
with
come on mushrooms there has to be there
has to be
where is the mushroom hello have you
seen mushrooms
[Music]
oh kill before
explosion pro minecrafter gamer yeah
slime's good hello slime oh
hello konnichiwa don't hurt me you're
fire now
hey sorry
sorry so you guys told me that these
can't actually hurt me
no they can't which makes it more
pleasurable to destroy you
oh damn i got so many 15. all right
i won't kill you then you can live just
guide me to the mushrooms
oh my god he's still here you're you're
doing your best mr slime
you're doing your best today don't let
anyone tell you different
i'm not even gonna ask what's happening
in here
that's disgusting
oh another cave face
slime slim what should i call you
you're my new best friend
rudolph
that's not even a sweat roll stay back
you're off
stay back you're all fun okay you're
with me rolf
that's faces in minecraft that's
disgusting
stop making those noises fishes here
you're disturbing me
don't be scared rolf i have you i found
flower rolls this is good sign
yep keep following me rolf we're going
to beat the ender dragon together rolf
my best friend throughout the whole
playthrough where are mushrooms
hurry up rolf i mean no herreral
take it in your pace rafarofan quinda
puerto farofan
[Music]
can i put a leash on him or maybe
oh golden apple maybe a fishing rod
all right you come with me ro
look he's wearing a little hat that's so
cute
you're so cute road oh my gosh he loves
boats
that's your favorite thing rolf look at
him go he loves
he just wants to go in water that's so
nice
when it's actually harder to find
mushrooms than diamonds
i think we have a problem are you scared
rolf
this will be the first time you see
sunlight
wow you're good
is that you get them rolf you're doing
it awesome
[Music]
why
[Applause]
everyone i love
we're gonna beat the ender dragon
together rolf
that's so cute you're so cute roll
ah
going back home i'm going back home to
lay down and cry
don't ask any questions just understand
i'm in pain
look at him go he loves just he just
wants to go in water
that's so nice
[Music]
was like father to me so apparently
there's mushrooms in the nether i just
have to go to the nether
what is happening here
hello is there the annual pig meeting
what is what is going on here
look there's mushrooms everywhere
maybe there's like azab so below i spawn
so many pigs in the real world they all
hurt they're all spotted here
[Music]
oh my god they have all gathered
to defend the pewdiepie in this fight
against the wither
okay so now we can finally make our
fermented spider eye
fermented spider eye ew why out of all
things
minecraft white of all things so
we need three water and we start off
with the eye
this is science okay this is big brain
potion of weakness what and then we need
to make it into
gunpowder swedish man discovers horrible
disease
swedish man discovers crippling
oh you hear that boys that means it's
done
we have it but ladies and gents we got
him
gosh i love this sword even though it
burns to myself and my soul and everyone
i loved
okay before we go allow me to flex on
you kids alright
this is what fortune 3 looks like
four diamonds
out of one block okay that was not lucky
seven nine
thirteen sixteen
oh 18 diamonds is whatever it's whatever
the online pets can die
with my my if my fortune 3 diamond
pickaxe
with efficiency 4 and unbreaking 3
disappears
then we're talking pain
that's almost as bad as swen dies which
will never happen
you know that'd be almost as bad as if
my sweeping edge 3 sharpness 3 fire
aspect 2 looting 3 diamond sword would
get destroyed
that would almost make me feel as bad
yes i laugh at my own jokes
hey look as rich again huh oh you know
what that means
of course i'm so stupid i know it ain't
much
but i made a promise
i'll finish it one day now we gotta go
to the jungle and spread some diseases
oh yeah
i forgot a thing never mind
okay so to turn the librarian into the
villager into librarian i need to
make first a book one two three one two
three
make a bookcase one and
i can make a lectern so this will be
his crafting table i never done this
i don't know if it's gonna work but
let's go gamers
now we go to jungle and spread diseases
hedgehogs
okay we are in the book area
could harvest the bookies
[Music]
but also kind of point there's another
chest i miss
so many bookies
you should be here wasn't this the place
[Music]
i feel like this was the place i gotta
check my own video yeah
okay let me check
it looked exactly like this room and
there was a torch on that wall
yeah he used to be in here he's not here
anymore
that sucks did i do all that for nothing
i'll come back and cure your body that's
what i said
i'll come back and cure you buddy
listen to me mission failed mission fail
hey freak off hedgehog did i
fortunately for us there's one other way
to do this
isn't that right pee pee poopoo
don't tell me this is another deserted
village i can't
so his profession is already gucci pants
but i think they can change profession
so that should not be an issue
all right gucci pants you're coming with
me
your days of italian leather is over get
in
he wants to go back to his friends in
the boat get in the boat
i don't get damn get in the bow
damn there's so many jargons here i love
the black one
we're going on the adventure together
don't worry you're gonna be really safe
with me
so far i have a track record of very
safeness
i've been rated five out of five in
their safeness scale
which is highest as it goes
what's that yeah that's the giant
meatball
oh what's that oh that's ikea tower
what's that in your new home no no no no
i have a different fate for you my
friend
oh gracious water sheep i bring you
humble offering
stay here stay here
rolf died for you oh
wait somehow he's already got a hat
where'd he
where'd you get the hat where'd you get
that what do you get
you're a fisherman now how
you were you were so passionate about
making gucci pants oh
disappointing
so if i put this here will he change
perfection
i think they also need a bed so
i guess i guess that seems fair
that they get to sleep as well so yeah
welcome to new home hope you like it
make yourself acquainted
and don't ever try to escape
you're here forever endeavor
oh my god he escaped but i know his
weakness
okay so now
we need to get a zombie oh my gosh
oh
oh no the zombie is going to kill me
ah what do i do ah
screaming pain oh no
zombies are back here you are trapped in
here
hey looks like you made little friend
today
get out of the boat sven
spend it sven
you don't have to guard them anymore
hey sven how you doing thank you did a
great job
good job now follow me no the zombie
died
what did you do i didn't protect them
from sunlight
god now i got to wait a whole day
oh it was my own fault sven
you think i shouldn't keep people
prisoners keep your values to yourself
sven
why is he not changing profession why is
he so set on fishing
you're not a fisherman you're a gucci
pen salesman
or the other thing that i say
oh my gosh i think you changed
profession
have you decided to cooperate at last
hey
very very well you're a librarian i can
tell
excellent
these are awful prizes by the way he
actually raises the prizes
infinity what does that do i don't
really know what to do
council of cheap
count o council of sheep give me
guidance
i don't know
i don't know how to kill the wither
[Music]
okay all right that makes sense what i
need to do
is i need to get my trident remember i
had that right i
i need to get an enchantment from
librarian
called channeling gosh you're creepy all
right i'll sell you my paper
look at him just carrying books all day
loser look how slowly he walks because
of all the pigs
they're taking up all the space are you
willing to trade me
the books that i want infinity stop
trading me garbage
very well very well sven come in i want
you to see
this even sven is lagging
sven we're about to make history
release subject
pee poo poos loyal army attack
there's no point in escaping
wow you are the lousiest zombie kill him
this is going to turn him into a zombie
villager
that's right everyone kill him
yes it worked oh my god yeah
yeah all right you see this man we're
scientists
we're scientists we made science today
look at that look at that food
okay so now we have to release a test
subject into his chamber
careful careful sven we don't talk to
him he's crazy he's crazy
oh my gosh look he's so scary angry
library
and angry librarian
hey
you're not invited you're not invited
what is happening what is
what it they're mad stop leave me alone
why are there so many ah
thanks for the help sven you're awesome
as always okay fellow zombie
so now now sven we throw splash of
weakness on him
as such i think i got it on myself as
well but i think it's working
is it working and then we're supposed to
give it the golden apple
whoa sven science
oh oh look at him look at him he's
transforming so no
[Music]
i'm scared sven i'm scared i'm staying
behind you
so this might take two to four minutes
and apparently this process gets faster
because we put him in prison
so i'm actually not that cruel as i look
i'm actually quite nice then
oh and there it is we got the
achievement
yeah we did it when we're scientists
hello how was that you feel better
little headache
so now he will trade i don't want this
but it's pretty cheap though so
literally just for a book
what am i gonna do with infinity i'll
take one oh he's an expert now fortune
two
okay all right making that money wait
here sven i'm just gonna go in kidnapped
someone
else hey man that's a nice farm you got
there
get in the boat go
you didn't see anything you didn't see
anything if anyone had that's right look
away
you know aristotle argued for slavery
that
some people actually thrive to happen
their master
so in reality i am doing a good thing
right now
thank you because now you're just a
farmer
with my help you can become epic
epic librarian culture then sell me good
stuff
okay cool every day i question what
happened to this let's play
you think this is one notch envisioned
when he made minecraft
let me just clear out your new home for
you why are you amazing
why this is not your purpose i don't
want your bricks get away from me
okay i want to kidnap i mean i want to
unwillingly escort just a couple more
people wow that's a
that's a lovely village you got there
that's so cool
get out of the boat i'm planning to
build another meatball
where uh the spawner is so it'll be like
two symmetric balls
smash like if you think that's a good
idea no
don't go there don't go there we caught
another one boys
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't tell me he despawned oh he's a
librarian
so you have decided to work with me huh
he keeps trading me the same garbage
come closer looting one ah
is there anyone left in this village
hey they have money idiots
get in the bow get in the boat
i don't care that you're making gucci
pants that's right
i'm not gonna lie i'm not i'm getting
pretty good at kid i mean um
unwillingly placing people at different
locations
so hopefully the villager here didn't
despawn
no he's still there look at he's happy
sven has kept an eye on him
good job sven what they oh they become
fishermen because i put them in the boat
of course look at him what
shepherd this makes no sense i don't
even know you could be shepherd
all right so you may be a little uh
you may be a little confused here wait i
got a pee pee
so
this is going to be the freaking room we
gotta make it nice for these uh
little uh this little guys
we gotta make sure they're in the right
mood
make it nice and soft you know what i'm
saying
okay there we go so apparently if you
throw
food at them oh hello hello
here we go take oh he took it
frick frick are they gonna do it are
they gonna do it
oh that was close they almost did it
let me get some more food sven
boyd's gonna freak boys gonna freak oh
boy's gonna freak boyd's gonna freak
what
oh look look like someone likes to watch
huh
hey grab this
yeah yeah yeah take it thank you take it
take it
does that remind you or something
oh look they just became librarians have
you freaked yet feather falling come on
give me
mending i want mending that's why i'm
doing this
i can't reach this one i made the big
room too big it's so
stupid oh they are freaking kind of
channeling channeling oh my god yes how
do i do it
oh i don't have enough money okay okay
okay oh my gosh
yes should i buy two just to be safe
yes this means we can if we find now we
just need to find
oh my gosh i'm so excited
all right the zombie army is gonna be
real
i didn't think i'd be so lucky i mean
mending would be better but
all right so i have to give them a bunch
of potatoes to make them freak as well
uh look away sven it's all yours
whatever you guys wanna like i'm not
forging anything
i'm not forcing anything i'm just saying
eat the potatoes and let the potatoes do
what they want to do to you
that's all i'm saying that's literally
all i'm saying right sven
[Music]
maybe moocow can you play some sexy
music
all right okay all right okay so yeah
feeding them food helps them
make a little make a little love
listen i'm not saying
do anything all i'm saying is eat the
potatoes
listen to the music come on
just do it okay so there's one thing
that i haven't done in minecraft which i
know it's
probably not the most exciting thing and
which is why i haven't really done it
but it's to go fishing
go fishing with me and my my boy
sven this is what i want to do
so i'm gonna do it
i thought why don't we set up like a
little uh
a little harbor area here next to the
these guys um sorry
sorry about what i did here
i'm gonna make it right
[Applause]
god damn this axe though
let's clear out this awfulness oh my god
diamonds i love them
oh my god
oh my god they're all fighting each
other idi ah
damn i completely forgot how nice sven's
house is
so i never gets to use it okay so we
need to expand the
fence area
this has to be the ugliest place i've
ever seen
damn my statue actually looks good from
this distance
i'm so proud
doesn't it okay so don't go anywhere
when i fence this area up okay
they are so slow they wouldn't even be
able to
let's make it a little nicer
[Music]
so they'll enjoy themselves
so yeah what i want to build is like a
little uh
a little docking area you know what i'm
saying
i need more wood okay so
we built our little area we have uh it's
a little nicer
oh look the trees grow that's nice and
it's time to finally go fishing
oh look i found the big ones man
oh it's so cute it's a water duck
oh i'm kidding it's used man i know
look who joined us virgin toad is back
baby
he's here to give us good fortune for
fishing okay i've literally never fished
in minecraft before this will be the
first time so you throw it out
and then you wait right sven
i'm trying over here you gotta wait for
something to happen
oh i got one i got one sven i got one
yeah but yeah another one
ah
when do i pull oh look you see you see
you see it's coming
oh yes
oh it's coming his company's coming he's
coming
ah nuts where the
where did you come from who did you
freak
what
[Music]
this makes no sense okay so we're gonna
make
a new fishing run you know i'll make two
and then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna enchant it and see what we
get
unbreaking three luck of the sea
is that good oh they're they're doing
the dance they're doing a
lob everyone be freaking
okay so we have luck of the sea what
does that do
okay so we're okay it's pretty
self-explanatory you get better stuff
let's try it out
come on virgin oh i see it
i see it
salmon do you like salmon sven
you can get treasures and stuff like
that come on
[Music]
oh my god i got puffer fish
they're so cute
[Music]
too bad it's dead this is nice because i
can overlook my area as well
except that eyesore
i'm gonna give it one more try
lure three okay that has to be good what
are you doing
get away from him dude you have your own
bed
oh i got a bakery in paling
silk touch that's pretty good
that's what i wanted to do could you use
a dispenser in a fishing rod
is there an automatic fish farm i'm sure
someone's figured that out
no no no
you scumbag you absolute
degenerate he's shooting my
turtles what is wrong with you
why would you do that the babies they
hatched they all hatched
they all hatched
ah what is wrong with people
just shooting turtles
okay luckily it looks like most of them
made it
oh my god so many they're so hot they're
so cute
look at this one
okay we just gotta keep fishing and then
we'll eventually grow up and we'll
finally finally have
the helmet so we can breathe in the
water oh it's raining
dang it if we had the triton we could
transform everyone
right now damn it that would have been
so good
since it's raining we have a little roof
it's so cozy
honestly it's awesome right sven
you keeping warm come on give me good
loot
low-key this is so cozy
there's me and my boy fishing
so i gotta keep an eye out on the babies
because when they grow up they'll drop
the chute
that's all i need
oh man i forgot i think you can feed
them
yeah yeah you feed them oh that's how
you make them grow
i mean
how am i feeding these tiny little
things
[Applause]
oh my god are you okay are you okay is
you okay
you can barely see the babies but
they're there
i got one i got a scoot i finally got
one
ultra they're growing
oh it grew up right in front of me
zero oh i keep hearing yes
how many oh my god how do my
how many do i need this guy's a slow
slow grower that's fine so was i there's
no shame
just because my pp got hair later
there's no shame about that
no shame at all oh my gosh i got them
all
how many i got i got ten i got ten baby
keep freaking
don't make me stop you eleven it
ain't ain't never stop so now
i think if we do like a normal helmet
oh my god yes
at last finally
turtle helmet is mine
[Laughter]
it matches my glasses so good
you like it sven he loves it
do you like it thank you
i worked hard to get it look so now i
have the bubble enchantment on my top
right
uh i should actually enchant this right
away
aqua infinity
[Music]
damn look how long i can stay underwater
now thanks to the helmet so
apparently if i do this right
i should be able to grab it it will just
take a long time
never mind it didn't take long at all
do i have it
[Music]
did i actually just place a torch on the
water because i
big brain
oh it went up didn't it there it is
i feel like i'm finally getting pretty
good at minecraft
all right i think i'm going to end that
episode there i've been playing forever
and i have to edit this now as well
oh my god there's one thing i want to do
before then
hey there how are you
you want to put black urine
i forgot how you tame a horde oh he
kicked me out
he loves me
black jargon
i'll take good care of you i promise
getting no no no black yo again please
oh come
on welcome home buddy
welcome home
all right cow hit it this is not really
the song
but whatever all right guys thanks for
watching another episode hope you guys
enjoyed it smash like if you did
check out merch if you want to support
the channel and whatever
be epic i really appreciate it thank you
and
uh next episode we're gonna try
and get the trident so we can turn this
pig army
into an actual army that's it for me for
now
see you later gamers
[Music]